en el wolfsburgo de alemania el primer
finalista de la champions league
femenina las alemanas vencieron por la
mínima al barcelonés san sebastián y
dejaron a las culés y en la posibilidad
de llegar a una final por segundo año
consecutivo encuentro muy igualado con
actuaciones para cada equipo pero que
terminó 1 a 0 a favor del wolfsburgo con
un gol de la sueca free to link a rolfo
al comienzo de la segunda parte
los culés lideradas por jennifer hermoso
lo intentaron hasta el final del
encuentro pero les falta definición el
wolfsburgo geographic su quinta final de
liga de campeones espera rival del duelo
de este miércoles entre el psoe y el
olympique lyonnais estas últimas han
ganado el torneo en las últimas cuatro
ocasiones así como ocurrió con el torneo
masculino alan ahora final entre un
equipo francés y otro equipo alemán